let's talk about the Year 2060 I I
thought the story was really interesting
uh pew research uh has done a little
study they're calling the next America
basically what America's demographics
are gonna look like in the year 2060 now
I read a book recently twenty thirty by
Albert Brooks and basically it's
everything that he predicted but they're
saying it's gonna take an extra thirty
years uh so let's let's look at some
stuff here okay so this is the the
racial breakdown and how it's going to
change massively and if you're one of
these white people that want only be
around white people you're not gonna be
happy in 2060 uh so by 2060 non-whites
will make up 57% of the population
mainly because of immigration ships but
also because of birth rates and things
of that nature uh and then what I think
is even more fascinating is this next
piece we're going to show you and I
believe it's animated okay so in most
societies if you were to look at uh
pyramids you have all the young people
on the bottom and then because people
age and die it's it's a pyramid so it
gets narrower at the top what's
happening and what's going to continue
to happen in America because of science
and because of our shifting demographics
uh is that we're starting to get a
square so we're gonna have as many old
people as we do young people which is
gonna affect the economy and is gonna
affect health and all kinds of things
been well earlier in a previous segment
on the show we're talking about the
benefits of Logan's run at people reach
a certain age and we're taking the
sanctuary yes right and I think this
chart proves the value the societal
value of Logan's run with Michael York
well your Michael York that's right
so Logan's Run and twenty thirty by
Albert Brooks which I hope they make
into movie have sort of ridiculous
because what he was predicting is that
the next sort of civil war we're gonna
have is going to be an age war because
young people are gonna be sick
of putting all their money to sustain
all people who keep living longer and
longer and there's gonna be less young
people and more old people um should we
talk about the young old first of the
race what do you feel in first we first
could yes very go back to the first
chart let's go back to first her I kinda
lost over that uh I just I just it and I
was born in 1960
look back at 1960 I mean we were winning
yeah we look at that white power 85 to
chant any Asians like who gives a [ __ ]
they're barely even over there that was
great those were good they barely talked
what the Jewish guys do in 1968 yeah
yeah yeah I know
I don't know personally if it yeah
really good um I don't even know is it
about race or is it about religion
because you know what the more you talk
about this and you think you whatever I
don't know if this is politically
insensate I don't know I'm just really
but brainstorming yeah all in here but
you know they said the Hispanic
population has increased so much and
will keep increasing is that because of
Catholicism is that lack of birth
control because of religious beliefs I
think it's all those yeah it just seems
like it's more it's possible that it's
more about that than about actual race
yeah I don't know but that's just my
thinking what do you make of the you
know Bill O'Reilly always talks about
like the the old America the fifties as
it was so great and we've lost our way
since then but what he's really talking
about at the 85% why so I think that's
what he's really harkening back to
without saying it um do you think white
people are gonna be okay in 2016 for
this is that a realization by white
people that they can don't have to [ __ ]
only other white that's a big the big
part of right that's a good point
everyone in that chart can [ __ ] anyone
in that chart that's and that would be
great to mix this whole thing everybody
has to do their part create future
people yeah that I enjoy very very much
yeah um okay so white white people are
gonna be okay but what is it that you
think that they're always what are they
fear well the first issue what do they
really fear change they fear and I and
what and I mean I really mean they fear
change in the sense that they fear a
loss of what they had and you know it's
human instinct to when something was
good and you feel it slipping away you
want to grab onto it and they're trying
to grab onto that way of life they feel
oddly threatened every time that
you know black guy raises his fist in
the air or a Mexican or a Salvadoran
fights for immigration rights or an
Asian goes to Berkeley you know and the
funny thing about that is these people
who are trying to better their lives
better their circumstances it seems that
these particular people these particular
white people are taking that super
personally right so it's not about that
as if it's coming from there exactly
well but it is they're not in a way and
they're up totally wrong some of it is
coming from them and that's you know
look that's okay it always came from
somebody it just went to a different
white person but the whole every
Republican lately and has run for
president on that theory of fear and
that fear is the things are changing and
the things you loved and the things you
knew and the things mostly that you
could count on in the future are being
taken from you by the others and you
know when the others were at 14% it
wasn't that bad when the others were 24%
they started to get a little
uncomfortable and now when the others
are 57% yeah like there's nothing we can
do to stop this so shouldn't everyone be
embracing it more that our society is
gonna change we had a different ethnic
makeup in the 1950s and it's gonna
change and be okay people don't think
that it's gonna be the same that's what
you're saying people don't think it's
well it's gonna be more Asian it's gonna
be more of Hispanic it's gonna be more
black but other than that it's totally
the same people are filling in the
blanks like racist mad lib style about
what goes along with that change and
that's what they're terrified of yes
we're doing we have a melting pot wasn't
there something about a melting pot
right yeah what about that melting pot
whatever that thing I mean in the
melting it was a great great concept
until Bill O'Reilly looked in the pot
you know what he was like holy [ __ ] pot
is [ __ ] Brown yes this is gumbo but
and for Republicans it's gonna be in
there do what he likes you know what I'm
fine with this melting pot as long as
it's a broth right totally let's act
like the very clear bra yeah but they're
doomed unless they mean it really calls
for a policy change because at
significant policy changes because
there's nothing as long as they're seen
as hostile to latina
there do that they have to get a
significant portion of that and the only
way to do it is by having some policy
recognitions I think that's gonna I I
think they'll do it because I think the
need to survive ultimately will win out
but there's no possible way to hang on
to electoral majorities without
cultivating some minority vote and as
Gina said there's you know the lack of
birth control strong families deeply
religious values there's a lot of
reasons to think that Republicans could
latch on to plenty of Latinos but are
you implying that that might be why Jeb
Bush said that immigration is an act of
love do you think it was a calculated
political way well I did yeah I mean I
think was Ken palooka movie might also
hear a bit but is other ways right you
know all right so final thought on this
the age thing which I actually think is
the most interesting part of this cuz we
talk about race all the time are we
gonna have a major problem dealing with
old people because they need to decipher
I mean believe me I love the Golden
Girls more than n but am I gonna start
hating old people because they're gonna
be mooching off the system we're gonna
be young less young people putting money
into the system and these people because
their sides are gonna keep living longer
and longer and longer well and it also
creates this sort of vicious cycle
because you know people aren't gonna
want to start you know having families
and supporting you know little teeny
tiny tots if they're already putting so
much money into supporting their parents
their grandparents other people's
grandparents right so which we already
see now Millennials are having kids way
less even rednecks are having kids way
later than idiocracy great movie
yep number that's all money accuracy you
must have seen it mister movie I have
only been up uh I can't remember
cautionary tale it is it's very moving
no a week but the the one Obamacare is a
is critical for this because you get the
young people forced to pay and forced to
buy which will help pay for it right I
mean it's incredible there was
significant foresight in that plus it
has the best panels to take out some of
those problem solved you see it's all
gonna work itself out
you